foreign
thank you for joining me today my name
is Jonas corler I'm Chief scientific
officer at Pacific biosciences I would
like to thank the organizers of
bioconference live for the opportunity
to speak to you today about the
application of long sequence reads for
more comprehensive views of human
genetic variation
my presentation will last approximately
45 minutes and I will be happy to answer
any questions at the end of the
presentation
you may submit your questions at any
time during my presentation using the Q
a panel you see on your screen
due to certain limitations with the file
conversion in into the bioconference
live environment some of the images in
my presentations will appear somewhat
blurry you can access a high resolution
version of the slide deck by either
clicking on the content button on the
lower left of your screen or you can go
to our website at
www.pacme.com forward slash BCL and with
that I'd like to begin my presentation
I would like to discuss the value and
application of pack biosequencing in the
context of the waves of the different
Technologies after the initial human
genome sequencing so after the human
genome um was sequenced for the first
time the first wave was genome-wide
Association studies so G was which was
focused on finding single nucleotide
polymorphisms or Snips single-based
changes in the genome compared to the
reference genome to associate them with
natural variation and also with disease
and I think it's fair to say that the
scientific Community as a consensus that
that effort had somewhat it had some
value but could not explain all the
different diseases and all the different
associations so as a consequence a
second wave came to be which was exome
sequencing now widening the
interrogation space of the genome to all
the Snips that are located in protein
coding regions
and so with exome sequencing there was a
larger degree of data and larger
knowledge but still it was found that
not all diseases were it was not
possible to associate them with the
genetic Blueprints and so right now
we're witnessing a third wave which is
looking and finding disease genes
genome-wide identifying the Snips on a
genome-wide basis whether they're in
genes or outside of genes and so this is
the so-called thousand dollar genome and
there's no doubt that it will bring
about tremendous advances in our
understanding of the genetic variation
and the associations for disease but
it's also worth noting that there are
certain limitations
the thousand dollar genome will not
include some regions of the genome
they're either not covered or are
covered at poor quality it will not
include haplotype phasing drawing the
connection of the Snips with respect to
whether they are contained on the mother
or on the father chromosome
it will not contain many forms of larger
structural genetic variations that are
of a larger size and it also does not
include the Myriad of the different Gene
products that are made from these genes
as an illustration I would like to cite
a few papers that highlight this
limitation this is a paper by a large
number of authors looking at the
different short read sequencing
Technologies and asking about their
value for clinical interpretation and
implications from these whole genome
sequencing events looking at the Snips
and the authors concluded that depending
on the sequencing platform used 10 to 19
percent of inherited disease genes were
not covered to accept its standards for
single nucleotide Baron discovery
similarly this is a paper by Hong Li
from the broad Institute looking at
artifacts in variant calling from these
High coverage High throughput sequencing
efforts
only used a relatively rare haploid
Human Genome cell line sample and asked
about the frequency of heterozygous
Snips so heterozygous Snips cannot occur
in a haploid sample so um they're likely
to be artifacts and he describes in the
paper that initially he thought his
sample wasn't really haploid because
about 10 percent of the Snips called by
the shortery Technologies were called as
heterozygous and so he looked and
validated some of these and convinced
themselves that they were indeed
artifacts and went further and
identified the root cause in erroneous
realignment in low complexity regions
and the incomplete reference genome with
respect to the sample as the two major
sources of Errors which press for
continued improvements in these two
areas
now going Beyond Snips it has been well
understood since the first diploid
genome sequence of an individual human
was deciphered this was papered by the
group of Craig vendor and colleagues
that non-snip DNA variation is also very
frequent and pervasive through the human
genome so in this paper the authors
described That non-single Base non-snip
DNA variation accounts for about
one-fifth of all the events identified
in that individual however they involve
three quarters of all the variant bases
and this suggests an important role for
non-snip genetic alterations in defining
the diploid genome structure what do we
mean by structural genetic variation
these are larger scale Beyond just a
single base change in the DNA they can
be deletions where sometimes ten to
hundreds of thousands of bases are
missing in the individual relative to
the reference genome Tandon duplication
where a certain region in the genome is
duplicated in tandem
variable number tandem repeats where
these tandem duplications occur at a
variable number and frequency dispersed
duplications novel insertions where
there is some genome sequence that is
just simply not present in the reference
sequence repeat insertions inversions
where a piece of DNA is just flipped
relative to the reference or larger
scale translocations where pieces of the
chromosome are swapped with one another
the limitations of the short read High
throughput sequencing devices for
discovery of these larger structure
variations has been well documented this
is just one example a paper by Stephen
sharer from Toronto and the figure on
the right shows a on the x-axis a law
plot of in this case insertions and so
on the left you have one and that's the
snip and then going further 10 a 10 base
insertion 100 bases thousand bases and
so forth and the colored lines indicate
all the published personal genomes that
were reported with the different
Technologies so 454 Lumina solid and
complete genomics comparing them against
the black line which is the human genome
reference genome with the Human Genome
Project that was done with Sanger
and you can see that in some cases with
the 454 and the Illumina technology the
papers on these personal genomes didn't
even contain information about
insertions above 100 bases so the curves
stop there for the other Technologies
there is some information but you can
see that there is a large gap in the um
available information relative to the
black curve which we know is true from
the human genome sequence so the authors
observed that high through high that
high throughput sequencing approaches
only detected a fraction of the full
size spectrum of insertions deletions
and copy number variants compared with
the previously published singer sequence
Human Genome and they posit that
generating longer reads can mitigate
these shortcomings
so in that context I want to today
present to you some of the research from
our users that demonstrate that we
believe there will be
um something else after the thousand
dollar genome and looking at just the
Snips is not enough so the fourth wave
We Believe will consist of more
comprehensive genome resequencing to
comprehensively profile the disease
genes with regard to all the different
types of variation not just Snips but
also structure variation phasing the
haplotypes looking at the splice
variants of the gene products and then
ultimately going to whole genome de novo
sequencing where you free yourself of
the reference and possible reference
bias to comprehensively profile the
entire genome with respect to these
forms of genetic variation so during my
talk today I want to focus on these two
areas and show how the long reads are
provided by sequencing can make an
inroad and can provide a high scientific
value in these particular areas
I assume that most of you would be very
familiar with single molecule real-time
or smart DNA sequencing so very briefly
um the we observe the activity of single
DNA polymerase molecules in real time
and we detect its activity as it's
selecting the nucleotides from the
solution and incorporating them into a
growing strand of DNA we have the basis
tagged with fluorescent colors that we
can tell by the virtue of the color
which of the four bases is being
Incorporated at any given time
this is done in a highly parallel
fashion where we have an array an
ordered array of nanostructures where
this reaction is being observed and in
each of those a reaction can potentially
happen this is in a view of the full
array down here on the lower left where
we have 150 000 of these potential
sequencing sites
the activity of the single DNA
polymerase molecules is extracted in
time to give rise to the raw sequencing
trace and then this is being converted
by the software automatically into the
fast a and fastq files all of this
happens in the instrument the PEC bio
rs2 which is a highly automated
sequencing machine
so the first
um thing I want to mention is that with
this kind of sequencing doing it quite a
bit differently from the shortbread
Technologies come key sequencing
characteristics that also distinguish it
from the other sequencing techniques and
the three topics that are important when
evaluating really any sequencing
technology are listed here and so in
terms of contiguity that is referring to
the read length you may know that we
have by far the longest individual
sequence reads half the bases that are
sequenced half the data is now contained
in sequence reads that are greater than
10 000 basis our users routinely see
reads greater than 30 000 bases in terms
of accuracy we also believe we have
industry leading standard routinely
achieving greater than 99.999 or qv50 or
what many many diseases I've only listed
a few of them here on the right it's
responsible for the regulation of the
immune system it's highly polymorphic
um basically every individual has a
different haplotype and the two
different alleles and of course it's the
major course in organ transplant
rejection and also important in disease
defense so this is an area that is of
extremely high important to understand
many diseases
the traditional approach to HLA
sequencing and HLA typing does not cover
the entire HLA Gene this is an example
for hlaa and so-called class 1 Gene
that's about 5.5 KV in its overall size
and the traditional typing approaches
with singer sequencing or with the short
read approaches don't sequence the
entire gene they only sequence x1's 2 3
and sometimes four
and the phasing the allelic phasing
making the connection between the Snips
for the different haplotypes is not made
directly it is either done through
supplementary methods for example
site-specific PCR or when it's not
measured directly it is imputed
statistically that you look in the
database and look which of these
particular combinations have occurred in
the past and in a nutshell make that
assignment indirectly and so you're not
directly measuring the connection
between the different fragments and you
it's very difficult to understand
whether this a belongs on the same let's
say maternal chromosome to the c or
whether it's connected to the team and
so precisely this phasing is at the
heart of improving the chances of
transplant
operations and also understanding those
diseases
the pack by a solution is full length
fully phased allele specific HLA
sequencing because of the long read
lengths that the technology provides you
can sequence the entire Gene all the
exons all the introns and then we have
software that splits out the Reeds into
the two different alleles calls
consensus and gives a very high accurate
um full length continuous long read HLA
Gene sequence for the two alleles
so this is the type of information that
you get the REITs and the method
requires no statistical imputation this
is an example of a 5.4 KB continuous
sequence for class 1 allele that that
was done from a reference sample from a
Japanese
user and it had 100 match with this
particular HLA type
and so that is the reason why several of
the hle typing Labs have now gone on to
um
have now gone on to
purchase a pack bio system so for
example histogenetics has selected
specific biosciences as a platform to do
HLA typing and they're one of the global
leaders in this particular field
similarly Anthony Nolan a uk-based blood
cancer charity has purchased a uh two
instruments and they're also going to
use it for advanced HLA typing
and uh with this new capability come
about
um new
um uh alleles that have been identified
and also correcting the database so one
hlab allele has been corrected in the
imgt database and four novel alleles
have already been identified and this
was presented by Anthony Nolan the
charity at the recent big HLA meeting in
Fe in Stockholm
a second example I would like to
highlight is
um based on taking advantage of both the
contiguity and the better uniformity and
the lack of the GC content and this
particular example is in the area of
fragile X the fragile X Gene is at the
heart of the most common terrible form
of cognitive impairment that's the
fragile X syndrome that is present at a
frequency of about one to three thousand
more in males than in females it's also
related to autism and autism spectrum
disorder it is also associated with
other disorders it's the most common
heritable form of premature menopause
and responsible for the so-called late
onset neurogenerative syndrome and so
the positive mutation is on the X
chromosome in a region that has been
extremely difficult to sequence
traditionally and so in a paper entitled
sequencing the unsequencable Paul
hagemann from the school of medicine at
the University of California in Davis
describes the ability of single molecule
real-time sequencing to characterize
this particular important Gene and
allele
and in the paper they described that
smart sequencing provides an approach to
sequencing that is fundamentally
different from other Next Generation
sequencing platforms and is well suited
for long repetitive DNA sequences so
this is a figure from the paper showing
that with smart sequencing you can get
through these cgg repeats that are
expanded as as a manifestation of the
repeat so these are the classic
trinucleotide repeat expansions where
you have sometimes thousands of bases
that are 100 GC content so it goes cgg
cgg and so forth and smart sequencing
both has the read length to get through
this region and has unique anchors
associated with the particular
individual sequencing reads that allows
you to measure the length and it also
has a lack of bias that allows you to
get high quality basis in those contexts
now there are non-sequencing based
methods that allow you to estimate the
length of this particular repeat
expansion but I think Paul Hagerman very
powerfully highlighted the necessity to
uh sequence and get the base information
for this particular region and this is
highlighted in this particular slide
from his talk that he gave at the
American society for human genetics
meeting in 2012 because this slide shows
that if a mother has one or two A's
interspersed in this C of cgg repeats
her risk of giving birth to a son that
has the full fragile X mutation goes
from about 80 percent down to about 20
percent so eighty percent with zero aggs
and 20 percent with two agts so that has
profound implications for
Parental counseling and for prenatal
decisions and and understanding
um the outcome of the disease
trinucleotide repeat expansions are very
common in many neurological diseases
um this is just a few examples fragile X
syndrome and a utr Huntington's disease
several ataxias myotonic dystrophy all
can be associated with these particular
trinucleotide patterns that are expanded
in the diseased individuals
and there are many of these in the human
genome so as an example trinucleotide
repeats they're about 140 000 instances
in the human genome 32 000 of them have
repeats of six or more they're also
dinucleotide tetranucleotide
pentanucleotide repeat regions
um other
retrotransposon elements line sine
elements and copy number variations all
forms of structure variation that are at
the heart of different diseases
um I want to give one other example this
is a paper by one of our users in Japan
rishita looking at Short tandem repeats
and he had a paper in bioinformatics
characterizing these with both alumina
and shortly technology and with PEC bio
and in the paper he highlights I think
two very important points one is in this
figure you see in Gray the reference
genome length of these particular
repeats on different types of the
chromosome chromosome 7 9 15 and 18. and
you can see that in normal individuals
they can be fairly reasonably short and
it might be possible to get at these and
sequence these
um with the shortly Technologies however
in individuals that have the disease for
example this
spinocerebella Ataxia type 31 these
regions are expanded to sometimes up to
about this is about 800 bases and so for
precisely the individuals where you want
to make a diagnosis says it's getting
difficult or impossible to get at this
information with the short read
Technologies
so for this uh cerebral spinal
cerebellum attacks F31 he shows that in
the reference genome
you have a sequence of Four A's and a t
that is 14 times over repeated in the
genome in that region for these
particular individuals he doesn't find
that at all he finds about a 3000 base
insertion of some completely different
sequence and he shows in the paper that
it's not possible to resolve that with
the short read Technologies he uses PEC
bio to resolve the canonical structure
of these particular of this particular
region and he finds that there are these
Penta and hexonucleotide repeats that
occur at variable numbers of frequencies
and the graph on the lower right here
shows the length of these indices on j k
l and m the length of these repeat units
for 11 different individuals and the
height of the bar indicates the length
of these subunits and you can see that
for every single individual they're
different so these are highly Dynamic
structurally polymorphic regions of the
genome where you really need the long
read Technologies to resolve them and
characterize them properly for this
particular regular brain disease
Ali Bashir at Mount Sinai working with
Eric shot highlighted that the tandem
repeats in the human reference genome
are systematically underrepresented in
this graph you can see that most of
these points lie above the diagonal and
so the y-axis is the biodata and the
x-axis is the human reference genome so
they sequence a well-characterized human
genome sequence with PEG bile whole
genome sequencing and found that the 10
repeats in this particular sample are
systematically much longer than what the
um on average than what the reference
would provide they can make this
inference because in the PEC biodata
they covered 90 of the tandem repeats
spanning 300 bases or more and can
resolve this particular structure
now why is it necessary to study
structural variation I don't borrow a
couple of slides from
um a talk that Mike Snyder from Stanford
gave because I think they succinctly
highlight on the necessity to look at
structure variation in addition to the
snip so he pointed out that it's very
common in normal human genomes that's a
major cause for phenotypic variation
it's common in certain diseases
particularly cancer and it's also now
showing up in rare diseases autism
schizophrenia and other psychological
diseases
why is it not studied more well it often
involves repeated regions the
rearrangements are complex and they can
involve many times highly repetitive
elements and so those are areas where
the shortery technologies have more
difficulties uh uniquely characterizing
those this I think is a very powerful
slide that he is showing where
um it per person there are about a
thousand structure variations that
exceed 2500 bases in size and they're
shown here on the slide with the red
hash marks alongside the chromosomes so
it's widespread and is different for the
different individuals this is the size
distribution of copy number variations
or structural variants in the human
genome and to give you a sense of the
scale down here the event size is in
this five thousand ten thousand fifty
thousand basis and the short read
Technologies can access directly maybe
up to a thousand bases and with reads
that now exceed ten thousand bases and
go to 20 and 30 000 bases with the long
repack biotechnology there is now an
opportunity to access all of these other
types of variation
um this is a table from a review paper
by Evan Eichler and colleagues showing
that many
um behaviorable diseases autism learning
disabilities schizophrenia are caused by
different types of structure variations
deletions duplications and so forth this
is a partial table in the paper this
this goes on
the limitations of the surgery
Technologies to look at these types of
variations has been described this is a
paper in nature genetics by a large
number of authors including Eric Lander
Chad Nussbaum from the broad looking at
mutations causing this particular kidney
disease and the authors described that
it was not possible to get this with the
short read Technologies but only by
cloning capillary sequencing and the
novo assembly that they find that this
particular mutation Harbors an
apparently independent arising mutation
that in in sequence that was markedly
underrepresented in the massively
parallel sequencing data and so the
reason for that was that they were lying
in extremely long about 1.5 to 5 KB GC
Rich 80 GC Rich coding variable number
tandem repeat sequences in the this
particular Gene The View C1 Gene and so
the authors conclude that these results
provide a cautionary tale about the
challenges in identifying the genes
responsible for mendelian Led let alone
more complex disorders through massively
parallel sequencing
at about the same time this paper was
published by Wanda O'Neill and
colleagues looking at a gene that's
related to the music one gene that's
mucine5ac important implicated in cystic
fibrosis in lung cancer in respiratory
diseases and the paper describes the
successful utility of smart sequencing
long reads for the novo assembly of
large repetitive sequences to fill the
gaps in the human genome
so the central Exon of Music 5ac had
never been sequenced not even as part of
the Human Genome Project figure one of
the paper shows that there is a large
about 50 000 base Gap in the human
genome reference and the authors
describe the application of smart
sequencing to resolve this Gap and to
characterize the genetic variability
between individuals so this figure from
the paper shows on the top the central
model that was developed through
non-direct sequencing approaches and
then the next four rows are an
African-American individual and three
Caucasian individuals and fully
resolving this particular region and you
can see two things one you can see the
reason why it was really difficult to
study with the short read or even Sanger
Technologies because all these boxes and
the gray
rectangles describe complex tandem
repeat regions and you can see that
there is difference between the
different individuals in the
architecture the general architecture of
this particular Gene
structural breakpoint detection so
deletions are generally regarded to be
relatively more straightforward to
detect with the short tree Technologies
because you can look at reads that
bridge such a junction there are several
papers that have described the utility
of long Replay biosquencing for this as
well and I want to highlight one in
particular which is looking at tumor
suppressor genes very important in
Cancers and so the authors here at the
University of California in San Diego
describe the
characterization of certain tumor
suppressor genes such as cdk and 2A for
with regards to Peg biosequencing and so
it was interesting to note that the
sequence of samples breast cancer
samples mcf7 is the classic breast
cancer sample it's been studied for
literally 20 years and the structural
breakpoint for this very important tumor
suppressor cdkn2a had not been sedated
had not been previously characterized in
spite of previous efforts including
whole genome shortage sequencing
also
um the non-sequencing method a snip
array the estimate for the break point
was 15 000 bases away from the true
breakpoint that was uh determined with
PEC biosequencing and then validated
with Sanger sequencing and the authors
note that the difference may be due to
the sign and line repeat elements that
Mark the region of the upstream mcf7
breakpoints and they conclude that
repetitive sequences are known to
confound structure variation analysis
and possibly explain why previous genome
sequencing studies of mcf7 have not
annotated this particular tumor
suppressor Gene breakpoint
inversions inversions are relatively
tricky to get at with the surgery
Technologies again you're looking at the
breakpoints but Ali Bashir again from
Mount Sinai I think very powerfully
highlighted that it is now much more
feasible to detect and characterize
these inversions and overcome some of
the limitations that exist with the
short read technology so this is a talk
he gave at the American society for
human genetics meeting in 2013. the tops
actually recorded So if you want to
listen to the entire presentation you
can go to our blog post and in this
slide on the screenshot that I selected
he shows that inversions can be easily
detected with the PEC biotechnology and
in many cases he highlights that the
inversions are not clean so it's not
like a piece of DNA that's simply
inverted relative to the reference but
there are regions where either sequence
is deleted or in this case novel
sequence is inserted at the breakpoints
and so that will make the effort using
the short read technology is futile
because they um will not have any reads
that are have any breakpoints and
Junctions and even the PCR validation
where you design a primer Downstream or
Upstream of this region will have the
wrong size and will not give you the the
validation
there are other papers that I don't have
time to go into where um that have been
published um describing the algorithms
and methods to resolve complex tandem
repeats with long reads is from and
Sinai alabashir developing a tool he
calls pack Monster and Evan Eichler in a
paper that describes the Reconstruction
of complex repeats in genomes using the
long read PEC biosequencing technology
so now going to the fifth wave which we
believe will be whole genome de novo
sequencing without relying on a
reference I want to give an example of
this because we have announced in
February the first data set that then
gave rise to a de novo assembly and I
want to present the ardinovo assembly
which is shown here on the on the far
right in the context of all the previous
efforts for de novo Assemblies of the
human genome over the past seven years
so starting in 2007 with print vendor's
genome that was still done with Sanger
then Illumina and 454 the different
Technologies High seek my seek and so
forth and the
graph on the top shows one metric of the
quality of these genome assemblies
that's the contig n50 that describes the
contiguity of these genome assemblies
and you can see that over the past seven
years there really hasn't been much
progress all these genomes are
relatively fragmented the average
counting and the counting in 50 is about
on the order of a hundred thousand basis
or so and so it took a new technology
and the adoption of new algorithms to
have a transition to a substantially
higher quality and contiguity about 30
times higher contiguity with a contact
and 50 or 4.4 megabases it's not only
the fragmentation of the genome that is
a concern but also the information
content that you're missing
this is a paper by Evan Eichler and
colleagues looking at limitations of the
Next Generation genome sequence assembly
so he took two of those genomes that the
personal genomes that were done with the
short V Technologies and looked and
compared them to the singer reference
from the Human Genome Project and found
that these short read de novo assemblies
were 16.2 percent shorter so they missed
about 16 percent uh that's about 420
megabase pairs of common repeats they
missed 99 of the validated duplicated
sequences and those were missing from
the genome and that translates to over 2
300 coding exons that were completely
missing from these particular assemblies
and they conclude in the paper that high
quality sequencing approaches must be
considered in conjunction with the high
throughput sequencing for comparative
genomic analysis and studies of genome
evolution
our assembly was recently uh
characterized and reported on in a paper
by Adam Philippi and his colleagues
entitled efficient assembly of large
genomes using single molecule sequencing
and uh in this paper that recently
appeared on the bio archives he reports
reference grade to Novo Assemblies of
four model organisms and the human
genome from Smart sequencing he
describes that the resulting assemblies
include fully resolved chromosome arms
and closed persistent gaps in these
important reference genomes including
heterochromatic and telomeric transition
sequences so in contrast to missing
sequence these sequences provide extra
information that go beyond what is known
in these model organisms or in the human
genome and so these results demonstrate
that smart sequencing can alone can
produce near complete eukaryotic genomes
at modest cost
this is an example from the figure this
is an example figure from the paper
showing the contiguity of the
biodenovo assembly which is highlighted
on the left half of each chromosome
these are the contacts compared to the
short read assembly of the same sample
which is on the right half of each
chromosome and the red dashes which are
a little bit hard to see you can see
them better in the high resolution pdf
version
um are putative gaps that are closed uh
even compared to the latest
grch38 reference
so this particular assembly has over 10
times better contiguity compared to
short read and even the original singer
assemblies to Counting n50 is 4.3
megabases on average they are less than
100 contacts per chromosome just as an
example the MHC region where HLA is
situated in a very important region with
the shortage assembly was in 60 pieces
in the de novo PEC bioassembly it's in
two pieces and um as I mentioned the
assembly potential resolves immediately
51 annotated gaps in the existing Human
Genome reference
a couple of examples
um for this type of ability and
resolution these are again large tandem
repeats this is a gene called filagrin a
very important Gene where mutations
cause uh Dermatological diseases dry
skin eczema it's also involved in asthma
this is a very difficult Gene to
sequence there's at least one user I
know of who purchased the instrument
just to study basically this particular
Gene it's highly repetitive it has in
the human genome reference this Gene has
11 1 KB repeat units and in the sample
that was sequenced with PEC bile there
are 12 repeat units and so you can see
that there's an extra copy in this
particular Dot Plot representation and
it's worth noting that just a single
long Peg bio read resolves this
particular structure uniquely on the
right here you see a single 16.3 KB PEC
bio read and you can see clearly there
are 12 copies of this particular 1kb
repeating
uh lastly the key region this is a the
killer cell IG like receptor region it's
a very important region in immunology
and
um like after HLA one of the most
important ones to understand uh immune
uh responses and so forth this is a
nightmare region to sequence even with
Sanger and uh in our in the de novo
assembly it's fully resolved right here
and the region the reason why it's
difficult is because it's very large it
can be up to 200 KB in size and it
contains repeat units that are on the
size of 12 to 17 KB so then
uh this is
um the description of the Kia region um
on chromosome 19 It's associated with
responses to infectious diseases
autoimmune disorders cancer pregnancy
related complications it's highly
variable in gene content and allelic
polymorphism and it's full of tandem
repeats of these highly homologous genes
and Dan Garrity from the Fred Hutchinson
cancer institute presented a work that
at the American Society of human
genetics meeting in 2013 entitled
complete resequencing of extended
genomic regions using phosma targeting
and pack biosmart long read sequencing
technology where he contrasted his
previous effort and that took about two
years to characterize this particular
genomic region with the PEC
biotechnology where within one week he
was able to fully elucidate and assemble
this particular this particular region
this very important here region
other efforts in terms of the
bioinformatic analysis are ongoing this
is a talk that Gene Myers so you know
Gene Myers from the original Human
Genome Project Gene Meyerson left
sequencing but then re-entered and now
uh is using his two pack bio rs2
instruments for the novo assembly of
human and other genomes this is a
screenshot from a talk he gave about a
month ago at an award lecture in Boston
where he describes assembling the human
genome with an assembler that he
developed in four days wall to wall with
a standard computational cluster no step
of the process takes more than 16
gigabytes of memory and so he got an
assembly with a contik n50 of 5.4
megabases so even higher than what we
and Adam Philippi were able to achieve
and so this demonstrates that also the
bioinformatics part is now there to make
the high quality Lenovo family of human
genomes feasible
in the last uh 15 minutes of my talk I
want to
um highlight that of course the genome
assembly is only one part of getting at
the information that's necessary to
understand uh the genomes and understand
biology in addition it is important to
understand all the team products both
with respect to their frequency and with
regard to the diversity of the different
isoforms that are created from these
particular genes
and the difficulties of resolving the
transcript isoforms has been described
extensively in the literature on the
left here is a commentary by Ian korff
comparing the
um
determination of the transcriptome to
buying a magazine putting it through a
shredder and having an army of
bioinformaticians then spending a lot of
time and effort trying to put that back
together also Mike Snyder on the right
commented in nature methods that's
really difficult way to do to take the
transcriptome shredded into pieces and
then trying to put it all back together
and the underlying reason of course is
that the transcriptome is
extraordinarily diverse and complex you
can have alternative first exons last
exons alternative splice Junctions
cassette exons where only one or the
other but not both of the exons are ever
present in a particular mRNA and so
forth and so down here this diversity of
transcripts is actually not a cartoon
this is um just one gene one of my
favorite genes tpm1 for which all these
different isoforms that were
um displayed schematically have been
found
knowing about the splice isoforms is
also important for understanding
function this is a very classic example
of bclx where you have one gene two
different isoforms have opposite
biological effects so if this particular
Exon is retained then this Gene product
inhibits apoptosis or inhibits cell def
if that particular Exon is spliced out
it the gene product has the exact
opposite function in that it activates
cell def
the limitations of the surgery
Technologies to highlight and resolve
transcripts has been studied more
systematically this is a paper by
Steiger and all the nature methods where
they looked at 25 different experimental
methods and 14 computational
algorithms with regard to their ability
to interrogate the transcriptome and
reconstruct splice variants and the
authors conclude that because of the
complexity of higher eukaryotic genomes
there are severe limitations on
transcript recall and splice product
discrimination that are likely to remain
limiting factors for the analysis of
current generation rna-seq data even
when even when all the constituent
elements are identified the Assembly of
complete isoform structures poses a
major Challenge and the authors conclude
that ultimately the evolution of rna-seq
will move toward single pass
determination of in-tech transcripts
which third generation instruments
will realize and I want to give you a
couple examples also from the research
from our users that show that this
transition is now coming to pass with
the use of long read PEC bio we have
developed protocols that are available
on our website adapting the kits that
are available for making cdna libraries
like the Clone Tech smarter kit to take
polyam RNA and turning that into full
length smart Bill templates that now
contain all of the coding sequence all
the exons and the five Prime utr the
three prime utr and the part of the poly
a tail this is then sequenced in the
pecfire rs2 and as you know it goes
around the adapter and then results in
full length CDA cdna reads that we call
reads of insert and those are then
subjected to an informatics pipeline
that we've also developed that takes
these isoforms builds clusters and calls
consensus from these clusters that then
result in the final isoforms that go
into the evidence-based Gene models
first a couple of targeted examples this
is a paper by Thomas utoff who and pnas
a few months ago of course is last
year's Nobel Laureate using uh the Gene
family of new recents and looking at the
alternative splice patterns mapped by
single molecule long read mRNA
sequencing so this norexian the norexian
gene family is very important for
neuronal development in the brain
forming a synaptic and presynaptic
connections and it was very difficult to
study because the splicing patterns are
very complex so the authors targeted the
particular norexian genes did an rtpcr
subjected to Smart sequencing and then
looked at the isoform patterns and this
is a figure from the paper up here you
have one particular direction Protein
that's norexin one alpha with the
overall domain structure then in the in
the lower portion here the particular
rows are the different exons and then
the particular columns are the different
exons and the individual rows represent
the different splice isoforms so a
couple of things worth of note is that
there's Exon 17 here which was
previously which is annotated in red
this was previously not discovered so
this is a new discovery from the paper
and then of course you have each of
these rows are different isoforms and
it's possible to then because it's a
single molecule technique to just simply
count the number of transcripts that
give you information about the relative
abundance of these splice isoforms so in
this particular experiment almost 250
uniquely alternatively spliced isoforms
were found for just this one protein
another example for a targeted approach
is in cancer looking at Gene fusions
there's paper in nitrogenetics looks at
the fusion of ttyh1 with a particular
micro RNA cluster and the authors had
hypothesized this particular Fusion
through the high throughput short read
Technologies and then used PEC bio long
reads to obtain full-length cdna reads
that directly confirm on an individual
molecule that that particular Fusion is
present and it resolves the various
isoforms that can be differentiated by
the different reads
there are of course many Team Fusion
events that have been characterized and
associated with Cancers currently there
are over 200 curated Gene Fusion events
in cancer and many cancers are
associated with misplacing alternative
splicing splicing mutations associated
with variable phenotypes and there's a
large number of diseases that have an
underlying cause in misplicing or
diseases that are associated with
changes in the relative levels of
alternatively spliced isoforms
with regard to looking at the whole
human transcriptome the first paper that
we know about is a study by Mike Snyder
in nature biotechnology that shows the
feasibility of deep sequencing
full-length RNA foam complex eukaryotic
transcriptomes the human uh
transcriptome at the single molecule
level I want to highlight a paper that
came out a few months later in pnas also
by hoop at Stanford by Wing Wong looking
at what is arguably the best studied
transcriptome and that's human embryonic
stem cells literally billions of
Illumina Reeds have been
used to characterize this particular
sample the authors applied python
sequencing and of the about 13 000
full-length cdna reads that they
obtained over one-third were novel and
it also included almost 300 novel genes
so in this figure on the right you see
the pie chart of 273 new genes that
previously had not been discovered and
then also novel isoforms and existing
genes with normal Junctions novel
combinations of existing Junctions and
so forth they looked at the expression
of the new genes and found that many of
these are differentially expressed in
embryonic stem cells relative to adult
or fetal tissues
and so these genes are likely involved
in the uh perturbance of the
pluripotency associated Gene networks
and so the authors conclude that the
mere process of Gene identification even
in these well-characterized human cell
lines and tissues is likely far from
complete
this is an example of a novel
multi-exonic RNA in stem cells here you
have the full-length PEC bio reads that
in conjunction with their isoform
detection pipeline gives rise to two
very confident isoforms of this
particular intron hasn't been spliced
out in these two reads in contrast the
same region shown here with the Illumina
splice Junction reads in red and then
this gives rise to the cufflinks
predictions and you can see that the
region is is fairly messy and and cannot
be interpreted
the authors in the paper also make a
final point that I think is very
important in that even though hundreds
of rnac data sets are being generated
their interpretation depends critically
on the completeness and reliability of
Gene and isoform annotations on the
species and cell types being analyzed
and so I've made a little cartoon to
illustrate this point so if you have
your short read
um uh rnac data the assignment to the
particular genes and isoforms critically
depends on the library the reference
that you have for these um particular
genes and so there are two Corner cases
case one is where you're missing certain
isoforms from that reference catalog and
so then what will happen is that short
reads that come from this particular
isoform will be misassigned uh into
isoform one and you will overestimate
the abundance of those particular
isoforms
more commonly the um on the flip side
the more commonly the converse is true
where people pool different tissues and
organs just to find out what are all the
possible isoforms that are uh in this
particular organism however in a
particular organ brain liver heart not
all of those isoforms might be expressed
so now you have an ambiguity of the
short read data with respect to not
being able to assign uniquely where they
go uh and where they come from with
respect to the isoforms so that you will
underrepresent the true abundance of
these particular Gene products and so
coming back to the paper this is a
figure from the paper that shows this I
think very powerfully in Blue uh in the
scatter plot on the right showing the
gene expression quantification of the
transcripts without the inclusion of the
new isoforms that were identified in
this paper compared to Orange where they
were included and you can see that
there's a large change with respect to
the um a gene quantification and two
more accurate rnac short read data
and then finally this is the first paper
describing a personal transcriptome
again from Mike Snyder's Lab at Stanford
a few months ago where the long reads
now facilitate identification of the
origin of the particular transcripts and
uh the figure here shows just one
example so in red you have
um all the full-length cdnas from one
allele from the maternal allele let's
say and then Blue from the paternal
allele and because you have full length
reads you can take advantage of very
small snip differences between the two
different alleles and cluster them with
respect to their chromosomal origin and
then very interestingly you see that
patterns emerge that show allele
specific splicing so in the maternal
allele this particular Exon is almost
exclusively spliced out there are only
two transcripts that have it retained
whereas in the paternal allele about
half of them still have this Exon
retained so giving a much higher level
of resolution and insight into gene
expression and the complexity of the
gene products
so with that I'd like to summarize um I
hope I've given you a good example an
overview over how new technological
capabilities the longest sequence read
lengths the highest consensus accuracy
the lack of sequencing bias and then
also a unique capability that I didn't
have time to talk about looking at
directly looking at base modifications
can lead to more comprehensive views of
genomes transcriptomes and epigenomes I
want to briefly mention one other
application that I think is very
exciting which is in the area of gene
therapy and genome editing I've
indicated this in the abstract this is a
paper by netportius and ayal hindel from
Stanford University
showing that the outcomes of genome
editing experiments can be much more
cheaply and much more accurately now be
Quantified with the use of smart
sequencing
gene therapy and genome editing of
course is a very exciting field of
research um there are a lot of people
doing it um and it's easy to perform
these kinds of experiments it's much
harder to actually figure out what what
actually happened and so in the paper
they show that with the longer reads
it's very easy fast and inexpensive to
quantify The genome editing outcomes
it's broadly applicable to any cell type
adaptable to any Target site it works
for all the common nucleus platforms
allows for optimization of the gene
targeting parameters and because of the
read links it can detect larger side
effects insertions deletions of these
particular Gene editing events
so with that I will stop but not before
um expressing my uh sincere gratitude to
all of our users on the scientists who
have uh invested in the technology and
are spending efforts and time uh
utilizing the technology driving the
technology forward we now have over 100
instruments um around the world and we
are uh deeply indebted and grateful to
all the scientists who are applying the
technology and the manifestation of
their work is over 200 peer-reviewed
Publications now that have appeared in
the various different application areas
and I encourage you to uh to look those
up they're all available on our website
and hope that you find them interesting
and adaptable to your research and
finally I'd like to thank everyone at
Pacific biosciences it's been just a
tremendous honor to present the
technology developments that are then
used by the scientific Community uh to
you today and they work extremely hard
every day to Hope make this technology
useful for your research as well
so with that I will stop and I would
like now to open the talk to questions
if you have not already done so you can
submit your questions using the Q a
panel you see on your screen
um so the first question
um I'm going to read the questions off
and then I'm going to answer them
um
the first question is uh regarding HLA
and it says is HLA typing only
applicable to large size DNA sequencing
uh what are the platforms available in
case of mRNA so the HLA typing um that
the pack bio solution that I mentioned
is
pertaining to the taking the full length
Gene you're not obliged to that so it
depends on the primer pairs that you
choose whether you're looking at the
whole gene or a part of a gene the class
2 HLA genes tend to be much larger and
so
um we have examples where we've done the
full length that can be up to 11 KB but
if the researcher is interested in the
subsection then you can also do a four
or five KB with respect to mRNA um
that's something that I talked with
members in the scientific community and
it will be very interesting and it
should be
um you know again depending on the
primers
um relatively uh straightforward to
Target these HLA transcripts and then
sequence them full length to look at
potential isoforms in um
nhla RNA
the second question is how HLA typing
overcomes the difficulty of 100 GC
content containing sequencing and its
accuracy and as I mentioned in smart
sequencing we have not measured any
appreciable bias with respect to that GC
content and so you can sequence through
those regions and get very high quality
just like with the normal sort of more
average um and intermediate GC content
and that enable allows you with Pacquiao
to get full length information
um the third question is has fragile X
been analyzed for peripheral conditions
such as multiple sclerosis Huntington's
um Parkinson's and Alzheimer's and to my
knowledge those kinds of studies are
underway
um and uh I think there are based on
these new capabilities I know that
several researchers are looking looking
at this area to my knowledge that hasn't
been published yet I think there may be
something at the upcoming American
Society of human genetics meeting I've
seen some abstracts that may talk about
that that meeting is on in October in
San Diego
um the next question is
um Can smart sequencing facilitate the
novel completion of the germline
sequence of the Lamprey genome and uh I
would say that um that should be
possible
um with regard to conditioning that you
can isolate DNA high quality long
fragments uh should I should note that
the the DNA quality requirements are a
little bit higher in smart sequencing
because we're not amplifying the DNA
amplification is the is the great
unifier with regard to DNA quality
however it comes at a cost of
amplification bias and you drop out
certain regions in smart sequencing we
can sequence amplicons fine but it's not
required and for these de novo projects
we don't recommend it because
um we see that if you sequence the
native DNA you get much less bias the
DNA stays in a double-stranded form at
all times and is never denatured and it
also potentially then gives you access
to the epigen genetic information
um as a in as a product of the smart
sequencing
okay I see that the the time is um
expired so um then that will be the last
question we have time to answer today
um if you have additional questions
please feel free to email me directly at
Jay corla at pacificbiosciences.com and
thank you very much again for attending
and have a good day